honey I'm home
oh I forgot I'm not married
a critic heard you gotta review food
fight good luck to you man
I heard the Nazis would have used it if
they ran out of bullets Oh critic are
you sure you want to review forward find
is the first movie to ever get a
negative percent on Rotten Tomatoes
hello
nostalgia critic this is the irony
grocery store we were hoping to indulge
your nervous breakdown by advertising a
series of trigger products mr. clean
mrs. buttersworth and Starkist tuna are
all on sale this week I or the grocery
entertain
haha
Oh
what I want me to do that
what the hell is food fight why does
everybody want me to review it well
according to our research food fight is
one of the worst if not the worst
animated film of all time worst like
worst worst it only came out last year
but it seems to be growing and
underground following at a surprisingly
rapid rate if our data serves correctly
this flop could be as popular as the
room and Birdemic combined it could
easily be the next big thing only a few
online critics have reviewed it so far
which means it's potential can still be
milked like a lactating Clarabelle cow
wait a minute so you're saying that I
jump aboard the bandwagon before it even
becomes a bandwagon I could be one of
the frontrunners or the bandwagon
potentially well if you'll excuse me I'm
gonna be at this ere one the most
popular bad animated films of all time I
wouldn't be too hopeful critic here's a
video the last person who tried to
review this movie how long Cherie is
fine
keep checking those numbers it's at
least you can do to indulge the
brilliant intellectual minds I decide to
write for you all the sauce well it's a
little hard to talk about this piece of
shit without addressing its background
the film was supposed to be sort of the
wreck-it ralph of food icons combining
copyright characters often seen in
grocery aisles it was also supposed to
come out in 2002 but due to production
problems copyright issues and even
somebody stealing the footage really
somebody wanted to steal this the film
was tinkered altered and pushed back to
ten years later but thank God 10 years
doesn't make a difference to such
Hollywood giants like Hilary Duff Chris
Kattan Eva Longoria and 24/7 Dodger of
controversy Charlie Sheen I'm sure all
these people will be just as big in 2012
as they were in 2002 you'll be
there's even reports that apparently 65
million dollars went into making this
stinker 65 million dollars well maybe
you'll be like Waterworld we're at the
very least the size and scale of the
production can be impressive so let's
find out by taking a look at food fight
good night mr. Leonard don't work too
late now just closing up nothing much
happens around here after died 65
million dollars folks clearly the money
is on the screen by God look at this how
could that amount of money go into
something that's so shitty looking what
what somebody actually deranged enough
to team up booby Bowl and Tommy was so
as this builds budget accountants the
money laundering from this must be a
loophole black hole so we see a store
closing down for the night cold market
Avila's market redundant much redundant
when the real world opens up inside I'm
not exactly sure how this works if the
store actually transforms at night or if
market ah police is a state of feeding
but this world exists and can only be
described as what your nightmares would
look like if they never rendered
properly you're excited and at the
foreground of this world is Charlie
Sheen's character dex dogtective hey
hairless hamster want some of this
and I know what you're thinking boy have
the Ratchet and Clank games really gone
downhill but actually it's just deck
saving a bunch of kittens from a villain
that like in both bad movies won't
connect to anything else in the plot it
is you the great dex dogtective who's
about to take a fall
fire raisin for every time I've heard
that one
hey what my mother would be so ashamed
okay it's just you and me fat cat now
for wait a minute
what was that character's name listen up
fat cat burglar I'm giving you one last
chance okay first of all Disney do
something second is the movie actually
so stupid that it can't tell the
difference between a rat and a cat I
mean look at that thing it's a fucking
obviously a rat 65 million dollars and
they can't even tell the difference
between a rat and a cat is it kind of
no-brainer you don't give 65 million
dollars to a person who would fail a
fisher-price barnyard animals game
squeak squeak give him more money
clearly we're dealing with artistic
genius here I pooped myself give him an
extra grand for that so the kittens are
saved by McGruff the crap dog for the
record I was also considering Indiana
bones and he heads out over to what else
his sassy black sidekick chill dog you
talking to relax bro Oh pizza hey I told
you dog great idea you my man brought to
you by the leftover racism for
transformers 2 as Wayne Brady has this
frightening combination of teeth and
fever dreams who gets excited when he
learns that Dex is going to ask his
sweetheart to marry him who is his
sweetheart I knew you find
what is that that scariness is
apparently sunshine goodness played by
Hilary Duff a cat Mets got four raisins
created by a designer who clearly has to
ask himself more questions about his
sexuality hungry tough guy
are you kidding how about we get Chef
Boyardee to make us a huge feast
amongest dinner and yes I do realize
that she looks much more like a human
and practically nothing like a cat
kids hard to draw did a cat snub you at
a party so you refused to portray them
on any form of bill the idea of them
getting married gets daredevil Dan so
touched that he cries palace but
sunshine has to head out before Dex can
pop the question
don't worry it'll just be a minute save
my ice cream I'll be right back okay
yeah I'm just gonna put this on yet we
all know that's pretty much what you're
saying sure enough she does disappear in
six months later Dex gives up the
dogtective business and decides to open
up a club called the Copa banana well
that's going on a salesperson played by
Christopher boy comes in and what the
hell am I looking at I'm Yakko brand
that's representative I wasn't expecting
any new product I won't know how they
live then it would iPad ahead okay this
one from submitting a stick figure to an
art museum embarrassing to shitting your
pants in front of Pixar claiming it's
your magnum opus embarrassing don't
we'll see how that turns out that but
what the fuck's going on here oh I'll
make space it's practically a dick
survival of the fittest medical odd was
it really somebody's dream to give a
personality to mask number five from The
Dark Knight
what would you trust a guy if you would
selling something it looked at acting
like this
good evening madam can I entrust you him
I wouldn't
it's called evil poison White's death
I'm sorry that doesn't seem like a
product I'd be interested in oh come now
it'll provide your business with a
wholesome attractive image of Satan's
anus that it so desperately needs
I'm going to need you in the crotch if
you don't leave right now what just what
the Jehovah's Witness be honest I came
on too strong didn't I
so the grocery store owner of course
agrees - such a puppy dog lookin man and
Brand X begins to be brought into the
store back in sam and max hit the sauce
we see dex makes his way to casa to
cameo which is the hangout for big-name
icons like mr. clean Charlie the tuna
and the California Raisins the funny
thing is that the people who obviously
said no to using their product icons in
this movie only really ugly really
bitter substitutes that I guess are
trying to stick it back to the people
who denied the use of their image like
this is their version of Chiquita banana
do I look like the Dairy Queen to you
and this is obviously supposed to be the
Keebler elves
the brawny man Angie a chocolate cereal
vampire
I wonder who that's supposed to be
chocolate vampire used to have cars
looking pretty good for biting it most
of them are portrayed as either stupid
ugly or not very helpful it's kind of
like the movies way of saying oh yeah
you missed out guys you too could have
been in a movie where farting is the
highlight and people tripping to other
people's butts I think we know where the
losers are in this deal give them
another grand and I guess the
representative of Brand X in this world
is lady X a supposedly sexy seductress
with the dead lifeless eyes of a plastic
blow-up doll and a personality just as
interesting to match
produce bars and all the supermarkets in
all the world she had to walk into mine
hi I forgot to mention every scene that
has Dex and it has to end in a bad pun
and I know you think you all nostalgia
Craig you say every about everything but
no literally every scene ends with a bad
pun time to banana split out of my claw
my problems are just a hill a coffee
beans let's snap crackle and pop a tea
how the ho-ho is can this be happening I
don't know if I can cut the mustard I've
got a bone to pick with this guy holy
chips
it sure does a body good some of them
don't even make a lick of sense
let's strawberry jam out of here the
only thing more demeaning than that is
all the sexual innuendos oh yeah there's
a ton of those in this too I want to
scrub your bubbles - it warms my heart
the way you love my raisins she's got a
real sweet tooth what chocolate you
already heat through to his hollow
Center oh those melons really there are
some stains you can never wash out Dan
see a man melts in your mouth not again
because a movie like this clearly needs
that adult edge from the audience
they're obviously going for what can I
say
chicks dig chocolate like there's some
grown-up somewhere watching this movie
with their kids saying hmm well I was
gonna turn this off and not expose my
child to such a piece of shit but then
an acknowledged I'm a pervert in a way
that my kid won't understand this movie
gets me the innuendos are so many and so
strange you have to wonder if the
director had some sort of other sexual
agenda on his my trying no this is a
fetish film between the innuendos the
cat lady and the fact that every outfit
this woman wears even a dominatrix would
say is too silly fetish pill and by the
way plant gloves really the design is so
weird that creates the illusion that our
hands are on backwards on top of that it
looks like your arm is melting and al
Borland shirt this is actually a popular
thing and I just never noticed you've
been through the wash plenty I can see
it in your eyes so that starts to notice
something along with stereotype number
20 here are you saying what I think
shoes
hey what's use Italians getting subsets
of bounces that being that lady hat is
starting to rub out the other characters
oh you have to help me Dex before I go
bald not that bald isn't beautiful I
don't get involved really mr. clean
showed up just for that one choke he
wasn't even around in the rest of the
scene and suddenly he appears when they
said the word bald and now he's just
stuck there look at him he's just
standing around like uh is there
anything else you wanted me to do was I
really just a pawn in your lame-ass
little punch line I have a PhD in
physics
perhaps I could educate the young
children watching about fluid or solid
mechanics or or I'll just look over here
yeah sure I'll show up when you make
another boob joke shouldn't take long so
Dex decides it's time to go get some
answers from the street everybody seems
to be searching oh my god is dicks
talking because dicks talking that they
get it over man game oh let me have some
reward for the erectus of rodent tell me
you wouldn't be shocked if they went
that direction but this dish is extra
spicy
yeah something else you'll notice is the
motion capture arm acting I guess
because the expressions in this movie
are non-existent all the acting comes
through how much the characters
awkwardly wave their arms
it's like watching c-3po have a seizure
but even he's somehow would have more
expression eyes based on these guys not
thick bold isn't beautiful all to
teacher where are you
so Dex and Dan go to get some answers
from you won't believe this another
scary demon of hell God when it detected
pepper duct tape any audio I'm just
gonna close my eyes and pray it goes
away
no it only got worse well at least
they're not pulling the ultimate insult
by giving him a stereotypical Jewish
accent but it's in the expiration
station and at the other end of the
store now you'd never make it there
before the supermarket opens pants
earlier groups you like to insult I mean
the human race is so vast and full
variety I'm sure you can find the
blackface of every single person on the
planet in fact why even focus on a group
why not just show us ugliness in any
shape or form you're good at that don't
even give a reason just use it in this
scene where they now physically exist in
the store again adding no continuity to
how the fuck this world works and just
throw in whatever terrible ungodly thing
comes out of your head
I call again and out this mafia is
punishment for me to repent all the
terrible things I've done in my life
whoo all right people stop in from
scaring the living animal Jesus out of
me out come fast
al come fast I want to cancel Firefly I
was the one who encouraged friend to be
an online series I won't know it until
Taco Bell to make a breakfast menu I was
the one who told John Travolta how to
pronounce idina menzel I was at work
I think we need a break here's some
commercials the love of God don't make a
movie out of them
you
so we come across a mascot who is a
chocolate vampire for a chocolate cereal
clearly this is supposed to be Captain
Crunch
I am the undead all right the undead you
know you're not dead but you're not
exactly living either sort of like being
in summer school oh come on that's funny
now that's funny
let's not lose our senses of humor you
have to have one before you can lose it
so they decide to get all the brands
together to stop the evil lady X and her
Brand X army but not before her head of
the guards tries to shut down the Coco
banana and unless you care to suffer a
long cruel expiration you will sing your
allegiance to Brand X oh no they got
some Korean on his too why Tim why I was
seeing if I could do anything more
demeaning than saying Ducks Rock this is
a very clear sign that I can Brand X
Brand X it's simple and plain Brand X
brothers it's just but Dex comes in and
starts singing the triumphant song
the French National EMA gee this scene
looks familiar in a way that unless you
saw the original movie this would make
absolutely no sense whatsoever and it's
extremely unlikely any little kid would
have seen this movie so this probably
makes absolutely no sense whatsoever if
you haven't guessed it yet they're
clearly paying oh my - barbed wire look
I know it's Pamela Anderson's greatest
performance but it's unlikely most
children have viewed its genius
so he comes back with a bigger army and
it looks like their battle has just
begun come and get me baby Wow
absolutely outstanding detail surely
they must have asked Pixar to do this
breathtaking work of genius actually
they did and after reading the script
not only did they send this terrible
animation as a joke but they also
attached a handwritten note saying go
fuck yourself signed by John Lasseter
but the director was so lazy he used the
clip anyway and Wow
look at this amazingness surely they
must have asked DreamWorks to have this
incredible work done actually they did
and after they read the script they sent
them this bit in the face render while
also sending out a picture of Spielberg
Katzenberg and Jeff and all mooning the
camera giving the finger but again the
director was too lazy so he used the
clip anyway Wow unbelievable Wow surely
such epic magnitude must have been asked
to be done by blue sky studios actually
they did and they asked if they can turn
it into a horrible franchise don't be
shocked if you see this coming soon to a
theater near you Hey look there's the
Twinkie guy I'm sure he's gonna do
something really big and really
important coming up after all he is one
of the biggest characters on the poster
along with these other icons who barely
seen in the movie he'll Dex and sunshine
are one third of their size surely all
of them are gonna get together and do
something huge in the movies climax like
say nothing pretty much do nothing and
take a backseat to graphics worse than
the money for another video and okay a
lot of you might be shouting that's
phenomenal false advertising in a film
there's absolutely nothing but
advertising but this is incredibly
common of even good films heck I once
saw Star Wars poster where the main
focus with the mouse droid and we all
know what a gigantic part he played
right the movie would have been nothing
without him
run while you can dex dogtective for
soon all heavy sitting up and begging
for mercy on jhana my badge there's
enough fetish you want this movie for
everybody
dan and the others try taking flight to
stop her as dan is just doing stuff you
don't do on an airplane it doesn't
connect to anything at all it's just
stuff mmm no Mick chocolate look here's
a 65 million dollar comedy perhaps you'd
like to do something funny with it so
tax makes it to lady X's headquarters
and discovers big fuckin shock that she
was behind Sunshine's disappearance the
whole time I'll just leave you to it
sunshine gets her hands untied throws a
race into Dex which he uses as a weapon
so he can untie the hands we clearly
just saw she untied herself oh well this
isn't much fun is it I think I just wet
myself
it feels rather nice oh that dish woo me
I'm sorry I thought you were I'm here we
were together I never stopped believing
in you Dix
uh did she go blind since the last time
we saw her I don't think she's looked
him in the face once during this scene I
never stopped believing in you Dix
it is Dex right unless scooby-doo took
steroids and somehow thought his speech
impediment but the spastic 80s rocker
enters their world
or was he always part of the world or is
he sometimes in the world and sometimes
not or is this all just some sort of
unique punishment program they use in
the matrix and the entire talent decides
they have to bring him down and now
finally we learn the big disturbing
shocking twist the villain of the movie
the whole time was the villain of the
movie so you built yourself a human
robot and recalled sunshine then you
stole her essence to make your elixir
for Brand X no just no all anyone ever
wanted was that sweet sunshine goodness
no one bought my beautifully genetically
giant prunes but how did you get in and
out of the store you're an IKE perhaps
if I do more ballerina twirls the answer
will become clearer when you look like
this you didn't get them to do anything
but enough about me let's kill you
so we partake in more sex puns
tell me something those melons read some
horrible CGI fighting
look out you almost convinced me of the
illusion of animation and we quite
literally have a catfight between the
two attractive women of the film the
bimbos mind get ready ladies cuz I'm
gonna kick you with a bundle and then
the Hat furry chick takes the era that a
hot dominatrix all while the men that
make wicked funny jokes about her melons
and then she gets turned into an ugly
woman proving once and for all that if
you're an ugly woman but no good can
come out of you
oh and there's something happy to do
with mr. Twinkie mr. clean to punch our
products but who cares it's done it's
finished with my magnum opus for the
horny furry s mmm can't fight boxing fan
fiction forum hood is finally completed
I like to do submit it oh no I just said
to get my Big Shot agent at Hollywood
why the hell do they watch 65 million
dollars for it
such Sun Chips laptop bag ugly gross all
I ever really wanted was you
well you and world domination
frankly my dear I don't give a spam you
know what just hit me this is the movie
that turned Charlie Sheen insane I
didn't really think about it the
timelines add up he constantly had to be
called back for redos and if you had to
return to this for 10 fucking years in a
row
wouldn't it kind of makes sense that you
would start talking like this it was
epic the run I was on made Sinatra Flynn
Jagger Richards all of them just look
like droopy-eyed armless children
good job boo bye good job so sunshine
agrees to marry Dex of last minute
messages throw in for no reason we saved
each other because the secret is inside
inside all of us whatever that means and
just when you think you're allowed to
flee this cauldron of I rape they decide
there's so much more funny they need to
get out
to see what's under than half the turn I
love you kidding we see things so much
clearer hilarious
so that was food fight oh fuck military
L much fucked a dead boy way to express
your emotions
charming so those food no wait call here
on the right sir hi sweet done so those
food really cut the cheese on that you
choked up shut up shut up every second
you speak is telling something I used to
love inside of me will you please just
shut up god this is that's awful I much
rather read the credits like a reading
of memoriam of poor people who dedicated
their life to this horribleness all
adding up to shit 65 million dollars of
shit and you know what the price of the
movie doesn't matter okay yeah it does a
lot but the point trying to make is
whether was made for 65 million dollars
or just sixty-five dollars there is
nothing to be proud of in this movie
everybody should be ashamed for even
acknowledging it exist
I feel like Beelzebub's Balzac just for
drawing attention to it the animation is
the worst they never look alive the
jokes are the worst they never want to
get a laugh the characters are the worst
they're all just stereotypes of
stereotypes the plot is the worst it's a
joke literally it's all written as a
joke but one with no good setup or
punchline it is one of the worst pieces
of commercialised dog shit I have ever
seen in my entire life and given the
roundup of movies I've done over the
years that's saying a lot in fact I
don't think human hands could have made
it I think something much more
horrendous and disrespectful had to pull
it energy together and make something so
awful
I just figured it out the horrible CG
animation the awful stereotypes the
tremendous we have funny humor the fact
that everything this movie is despicably
awkward and unnatural my god I know
directed this film Oh Sonny me more
foreshocks lots of more fat sock
there's a comedy Agatha for the food
fighter - ah propels mother fucking
heart I stab at thee
it is done but the evil will never truly
go away this is the words animated film
I have ever seen
hands down no comparison it's scars are
left deep inside of me why did I do it
for you
I did it for you because I know that I
have seen the worst I know that no other
form of animation will ever be worse
than food fight and because of that I
know for a fact that this film will
forever in the history books always be
seen as nasty yep since you started to
review the movies popularity has already
died out that was a fuckin Hef oh my god
well that's practically five years in
internet time yes people knew it was
going to be the next popular thing to
mock so they decided not to mock it at
all wait
so the popularity of something can fade
even before it becomes popular mm-hmm we
call it the hipster effect knowing
something is going to be ironically cool
suddenly makes it traditionally cool so
would it be ahead of the curve they
decide to not even make it ironically
cool hell even thinking about it
probably cuts its lifespan in half so
you're telling me that sitting through
all this misery the worst animated film
of all time was a complete waste of time
sorry buddy and there's nothing I can do
about it not unless you want to somehow
do a review of the Attorney General of
Crimea she is on fire right now oh she
is adorable I just want to eat her off
oh look she smiled oh just like the
Jennifer Lawrence of warfare I just want
to pinch her cheeks but I respect her
- all those critics foolish enough to
think that they can review food fight I
won't lie - about your chances you have
my sanity's it will not leave you the
same way I found you
it's scars deep there is anyone out
there
damn insane enough to try and take out
this film all you have to say is be
strong be brave
me
you
survival of the fittest leather